JUDGE RENSLAYER
Loki Laufeyson...
I sentence you to be reset.
LOKI
You ridiculous bureaucrats
will not dictate
how my story ends!
JUDGE RENSLAYER
It's not your story, Mr. Laufeyson.
It never was.
GUGU MBATHA-RAW
Renslayer works for the TVA,
this bureau that really
maintains the integrity of time.
JUDGE RENSLAYER
If anything goes sideways, it's on you.
MOBIUS
I feel like I'm always looking up to you.
It's appropriate.
GUGU MBATHA-RAW
She's powerful.
She's well-respected.
TOM HIDDLESTON
She has enormous authority.
KATE HERRON
She's someone that has worked her way
up the ranks. I think
Gugu really captured that journey.
MOBIUS
Why do you get to keep
all the trophies
from my cases?
JUDGE RENSLAYER
Because I approve the missions.
MOBIUS
Good point.
GUGU MBATHA-RAW
There's a lot of betrayal and mischief.
It's really wonderful.
JUDGE RENSLAYER
Cheers.
GUGU MBATHA-RAW
I'm excited to watch the show myself!